[Music]
illinois is home to over 35 fortune 500
companies scattered across chicago its
suburbs as well as other parts of the
state but in recent months three major
corporations have announced their exits
the chicago area losing another
corporate headquarters caterpillar is
moving to texas boeing is expected to
move its corporate headquarters to
virginia billionaire ken griffin is
relocating his hedge fund firm
headquarters from chicago to miami so
anytime that you know major names depart
a metropolitan area it's a blow to sort
of you know that metropolitan area's ego
so what does the exit of several major
employers mean for the state and how
does it connect to broader economic
trends you know you hear companies all
across the country talk to about the
business community saying oh we may
leave we might do it well it's happening
here those are big announcements tom
stringer specializes in site selection
at the accounting network bdo so you
know chicago would be wise to listen try
and understand the why and then try to
solve those issues that why is different
according to each company citadel's ceo
said he views florida as a better
corporate environment and has previously
complained about chicago's crime
caterpillar said the move supports its
strategy for profitable growth and said
it wasn't getting any economic or tax
incentives related to the move
caterpillar has steadily invested in
right-to-work states like texas over the
last decade and boeing's announcement
was a long time coming according to
analysts like stringer when the boeing
decision to come from seattle to chicago
took place to
really a lot of fanfare but it was kind
of strange at the time that boeing
didn't pick washington then given the
level of defense work that they do in
the regulatory environment faa
relationships lawmakers and unions have
previously criticized boeing for the
remoteness of a chicago base from its
jetliner operations in the seattle area
in a statement boeing said northern
virginia makes strategic sense for our
headquarters with the proximity to our
global customers and stakeholders as
well as world-class engineering and
technical talent
the move brings boeing closer to its
largest customer the pentagon as well as
to lawmakers and regulators boeing said
its ceo and cfo will move but the
majority of its thousand employees will
remain in illinois
meanwhile caterpillar announced roughly
230 of its corporate roles will move to
the new texas headquarters with around
17 000 jobs remaining in illinois
if those headquarters jobs are small but
highly compensated making a lot of
decisions having a lot of those folks
come in
using a lot of corporate services active
in the community even though it might be
a limited number of jobs that that that
defection hurts significantly the moves
are seen as a setback for chicago and
illinois leaders efforts to bring more
companies to the area in late june the
chicago mayor's office said citadel's
exit was disappointing the office added
that chicago's economic outlook has
never been stronger and cited more than
35 new company relocations and 58
expansions made this year
the illinois governor's office did not
respond to a request for comment on the
company's exiting in a previous
statement governor jb pritzker said the
state continues to be a leader in
attracting companies so having
corporations uh headquartered in your
area is is both important from a jobs
perspective but also sort of a
prestige standpoint and a company's
relocation could have ripple effects
throughout the local economy whether
that's the turkey sandwich for lunch the
dry cleaning that's pumping money into
their local economy back in the in the
chicago suburbs or if you live in an
apartment downtown so those little
economic catalysts will be gone and that
will hurt according to a recent report
approximately 4.4 jobs are created in
the local non-tradable sector for every
job created in the local high-tech
sector some non-tradable jobs are
lawyers dentists and retail clerks and
in the post-pandemic economy some
analysts say workers are still in the
driver's seat people are definitely out
in front taking the lead making
lifestyle decisions and companies are
playing catch-up workers are moving from
the coast to the middle of the country
in florida and by many measures red
states those that lean republican have
recovered faster economically and
democratically new blue ones following
the national trends there's just so much
more growth in the south and the
southwest and that's where you know some
of these companies have have moved this
movement has implications illinois is
one of seven states that lost a
congressional seat following the 2020
census while texas and florida the new
sites of caterpillar and citadel are two
of six states that gained at least one
seat the loss of a congressional seat uh
is partly you know in illinois's case it
is is because of the true sort of loss
of population although it was very close
to sort of zero growth but more
importantly it's just not growing as
fast as other areas one area in
particular is picking up midwestern
workers and employers the dallas fort
worth region in texas in particular is
where a lot of those folks are coming
dfw similar to chicago for a lot of
business reasons in terms of office
environment diverse corporate services
ease of travel back and forth across the
country so dallas has always been
chicago's kind of shadow shadow
competitor florida is similarly
benefiting from relocations as it's
beginning to see an effect on its
economies and finances florida is on
track to register a record budget
surplus for the fiscal year that ended
june 30th which it attributes in part to
new residents both florida and texas do
not have individual income taxes
illinois however has a flat income tax
rate of nearly 5
those taxes account for around half of
the state's total revenue
the illinois chamber of commerce has
advocated for streamlining regulations
and reducing taxes in the state
chicago is still attracting companies
with its roots as an economic hub for
the midwest along with its international
airport so even as several companies
exit illinois other corporations like
kellogg's snack division are expecting
to move in and google says it plans to
purchase a new office in the area
chicago's famed thompson center if it
wasn't evident before then surely it is
crystal clear now google is one of
chicago's most important companies tech
firms had really been starting to bulk
up and grow
uh in the chicago area before the
pandemic but that of course was very
much slowed down by the pandemic so this
will be an interesting you know new
wrinkle uh in downtown chicago to keep
an eye on as companies try to attract
new hires some states are also working
to recruit companies certain states are
extraordinarily proactive and cities are
extraordinarily proactive in recruiting
based on things like quality of life uh
incentives workforce showing that and
touting the benefits of a certain
community that's because it increases
quite frankly tax flow to a community
it's a return on investment you bring
customers in if you will for example
virginia senator mark warner said he had
been lobbying boeing's senior leadership
for over a year to move its headquarters
to his state i see the cities that are
really winning are those that are in the
hunt in the game and are out knocking on
doors going to meet with companies those
might not have immediate results but two
three four years down the line
when a ceo changes over or the key
decision makers change over that's
remembered and that's often when it
becomes successful
[Music]